i'm feeling good uh
i would say i had maybe one or two days
where i felt symptoms
and even then it wasn't too bad i had a
cough
and a little bit of shortness of breath
but uh
now i would say i feel i feel feel good
i feel normal
um still can't work out i gotta wait
until uh
i could have went and got retested uh
this week um
i just decided i mean it won't hurt just
to wait another week and uh just give
myself more time to uh
rest up but uh i feel good
i got corona and it really didn't affect
me much
but you know some a lot of people have
have kids
you know they may have kids with asthma
they may have newborn babies
um their parents or grandparents may
live with them
and uh i just um
that we have to find a way just to make
sure that the players
and their families and even and the
coaches also
and their families um aren't put at risk
i do hope that we have a season um
but i mean it just has to be it has to
be right it has
it has to uh we gotta put the health of
the players and the coaches and
and the support staff first um
i mean i think that's important
ezekiel did on twitch yesterday with his
thoughts on
his own experience with covert 19. and
look it sounds like it was mild but to
the extent that a professional athlete
can't work out that tells you
it's not just mild if it knocks you out
of your workout routine
unless you're looking for an excuse to
get out of your workout routine which i
am very good at
but if it if it results in the doctor
saying you can't work out that tells you
it's not just some
minor little bug like if you get the
cold or the flu you're knocked out of
your workout routine for a day or two or
you push
through it something like this if you're
looking at a week or two of not
exercising it's it's it's not some minor
thing
and he's right about they need to have a
plan and they need to be thinking about
and the players and coaches need to be
thinking about their own situations
chris because
even though the players for the most
part aren't going to be at risk of a
serious outcome
older coaches coaches with pre-existing
conditions
coaches who have had cancer coaches who
may have diabetes whatever the case may
be
and the people you live with is zeke
said you may live with your grandparents
you may have a young child that has
asthma you may have people around you
that if this
this virus gets into their bodies they
are not
going to just have a mild case of it so
these are all things that need to be
taken into account and that's why i've
said all along
and i hope they can get to this point
and i hope that testing is the thing
that that bridges this gap and helps
football to happen
i've said you need to have basically an
airlock on the front door to the
facility
and everyone who shows up goes in there
one at a time
gets tested the result comes back in
five minutes
if you're negative you're allowed in if
you're positive you get pulled into the
quarantine
protocol and on the way out right in the
event that somehow some way you got
infected while you're in the facility
for 12 days getting ready for the next
game
you get tested again because they don't
or at least they shouldn't want to set
loose onto the community
whether it's the player's house or
anywhere else they may go somebody who's
positive
constant monitoring two tests a day
every day you show up for work one on
the way in one on the way out i think
that's the only way to do it responsibly
and that's where the nfl pa has been on
this whatever we do cannot put
an unfair and undue impact and burden on
the community
and you know when you look at what zeke
had to say you
read between the lines and you piece it
all together it is going to be an undue
impact on the community
unless you're making damn sure that
you're not sending guys home who may be
positive
well i mean as you know and we're around
a lot of players players are good people
i mean 99 of the players in the nfl are
caring
people they're guys that have come from
not a lot
they realize they've been fortunate they
want to give back
they you know these are these are
ezekiel i mean yeah
he i don't think he's worried about
himself like he said he's
thinking about teammates family things
like that
so that just shows you where his brain
is at so uh you know mike
there is so many things first off you
know you're right it it is serious
you know there's no doubt about that hey
i mean it's serious when the doctor
tells you you got bronchitis
you know you can't work out or do
anything or it can become pneumonia if
you push through it
well with with kobit 19 sorry i don't
know what happened with my phone there
with kobe 19
i mean yeah you try to work out with
that you might end up dead i mean forget
pneumonia
so yes it is more serious but of it you
know the other thing too mike
you know will the nfl do something
with maybe coaches or
other front office people who have
maybe the health issues that you're
talking about right
like maybe the nfl needs to do like
listen if you have an offensive line
coach who
has asthma problems or maybe like you're
saying
has fought off cancer not long ago in
the history of their life or whatever
maybe we don't let those people in the
building this year maybe
maybe maybe we don't even risk that
maybe that's the smart thing to do
and you know yes you have to hire some
assistant to be a guy that could be
there in person but maybe that coach has
to coach from home in the meetings and
zoom in
in the zoom fashion or whatever it may
be
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports